[موسيقى]
ما تقوليش فيش نصيب اترد البستان الرحيب
عشانه فيه فيل كبير والغنمات يذبحهم الديب
ما تقوليش فيش نصيب اروح الناصره ودير
الغصون والعديسات والنقيب اصلي بالاقصى
واحرس القيامه واشرب قهوه عرب الهيب ما
تقولي فيش نصيب ارسم حيفه عند المغيب
عشانه يافع عروس فلسطين صاروا يقولوا لها
تلبيب ما تقوليش فيش نصيب سارق دارك
الحرامي وزارع من حولك لهيب والغرب سند
بظهره والشرق صمته مريب ما تقولي فيش نصيب
اقول لك مهما جار الزمن وطال رح يبقى
الغريب غريب وبيتي صق وح حق ووعد وبيتي سق
وحق ووعد يرجع والبلد السليب راجع راجع زي
الشمس تشرج من بعد المغيب طول روحك بعد
شوي الا كل ات قريب تكتب فتاه
فلسطينيه الى
العناوين محمد الضيف ينازل بنيامين
نتنياهو في قلب
مستوطنات طوفان الاقصى ترد عليه اسرائيل
بمجازر بحق
المدنيين مطار بن جوريون يزدحم
بالمغادره في حاويات
النفايات شرطي مصري يقتل سائحين
اسرائيليين في
الاسكندريه وزير الدفاع الاسرائيلي يصف
الفلسطينيين بالحيوانات
البشريه مجنده اسرائيليه
تسال هل هناك عملاء لحماس داخل الجيش
الاسرائيلي سيناريو يوم القيامه في
اسرائيل يحذر منه باحث عبري
مشهور الجيش السوري يحرق ادلب وريف حلب
بقنابل النابالم المحرمه
[موسيقى]
دوليا
مرحبا ح طبي لحاله مرضيه نفسيه يطلق عليها
بالعربيه تبدد الشخصيه يعيش المصاب بها
نوعا من الانفصال عن الواقع ويشعر بان ما
يجري حوله غير حقيقي اصيب الكثير من العرب
بالدي برسونال سيون هذا الاسبوع وقد
اتهموا كتائب القسام وسائر فصائل المقاومه
الفلسطينيه بالتسبب باصابتهم فلم يعهدوا
الصفرين على يمين ارقام القتلى
الاسرائيليين والثلاثه اصفار مع ارقام
جرحاهم ولم يالف العرب ان الفلسطينيين
يمهلون الاسرائيليين لمغادره مدنهم قبل
قصفها كما فعل ابو عبيده الناطق الميداني
لكتائب
القسام علما يضيف المعلقون ان العرب دعاه
سلام وقد طرحت دولهم مبادره السلام
العربيه الشهيره لكن اسرائيل ما تزال
ترفضها وتسحب يدها من السلام العادل
والشامل انه اسوا يوم في تاريخ اسرائيل
على الاطلاق لم يحدث من قبل ان قتل هذا
العدد من الاسرائيليين بسبب حادث واحد
نهيك عن نشاط العدو في يوم واحد ماذا فعل
الفلسطينيون بالشباب العرب يسالوا مراقب
وهم الذين اعتادوا على ان يكون طوفان
الاقصى فائضا حبر على ورق بيانات رسميه
تدعي وصلا بالقدس لقد الفت الاجيال
العربيه مصطلح المعركه التي لاصوت يعلو
فوق صوتها لكنها لم تكن الا صوتا على ظهر
كل ديك يرفض النقنقه كالدجاج ويرفع اذانا
[موسيقى]
للفجر
مراقب عربي اخر واقعي يقول لا تفرحوا
كثيرا فما تفعله حماس وان كان مقاومه غير
مسبوقه لكنه يجر على الفلسطينيين ايضا
تهلكه غير
مسبوقه بين المراقبين الذين لا نطلق
الاحكام المسبقه على اي منهما ندور في هذه
الحلقه ونبدا من بدايه الطوفان مع قائد
كتائب القسام محمد الضيف الذي حل رجاله
ضيوفا ثقالا على جنود بنيامين
نتنياهو وقد قيل في محمد الضيف انه استطاع
ان يحرك بكرسيه المتحرك ركود السنين فيما
يرى البعض انه يجر المنطقه الى الدمار
انتم ماذا ترون ارائكم مهمه دونو ان رغبتم
فاننا نعلن بدء عمليه طوفان الاقصى كما
اننا نعلن بعون الله وقوته ان الضربه
الاولى من عمليه ال طوفان الاقصى والتي
استهدفت مواقع العدو و مطاراته وتحصيناته
العسكريه خلال الع دقيقه الا الاولى قد
تجاوزت 5000 صاروخ وقذفه مجاهدون الابرار
هذا يومكم لتفهموا هذا العدو المجرم انه
قد انتهى زمنه اقتلوهم حيث ثقفتموهم
واخرجوهم من حيث اخرجوكم لا تقتلوا الشيوخ
والاطفال وازيل هذا الدنس عن ارضكم
ومقدسات تقول تقارير ان محمد الضيف هو
صاحب قرار الحرب والسلم في حركه حماس وفي
قطاع غزه فمن هو هذا الرجل الخفي والمطلوب
رقم واحد لاسرائيل يوصف بالرجل المستحيل
فهو مطلوب لاسرائيل منذ ثلاثه عقود يعيش
بلا هواتف يصفه اعلام اسرائيل بصاحب
الارواح التسعه فكل محاولات اغتياله فشلت
يعتقد انه صاحب قرار اعلان الحرب على
اسرائيل فهو صانع القوه وعقل القسام
والرجل الذي بنى قدرات حماس الصاروخيه
اسمه محمد الضيف وكنيته ابو خالد هو قائد
اركان كتائب عز الدين القسام الجناح
العسكري لحركه حماس تقول اسرائيل ان
محاولات الاغتيال المتتابعه تركته بعين
واحده ويد واحده وبلا قدمين لكن تحركاته
العسكريه لم تتوقف قتل زوجته واطفاله في
قصف اسرائيلي على غزه عام
2014 اعتقد تلبيب انه قتل مع عائلته لكنه
نجا وهو الذي كان ينجو في كل مره بين حرب
اكتوبر
1973 وطوفان اكتوبر
2023 50 عاما من شعارات اللاءات الثلاث
والصمود والتصد والامه العربيه الواحده
ذات الرساله الخالده اف طوفان الاقصى يغير
قواعد المواجهه فيوقع فصيل مقاومه شعبيه
قتل وجرحى واسرى من مختلف الرتب العسكريه
في صفوف
الاسرائيليين اكثر مما اوقعته حروب
الانظمه العربيه تحدثنا اليوم عن عشرات
الاسرى من ضباطهم وجنود ونريد ان نطمئنكم
بان اعداد اسراكم اكثر من ذلك باضعاف
مضاعفه يوم او بعض يوم كان كافيا لتقلب
كتائب القسام الذراع العسكري لحركه حماس
موازين قوه مع اسرائيل هذه الصور كانت قبل
فجر السابع من اكتوبر اقرب الى خيال
اسرائيل راتها بعيده وجعلها الفلسطينيون
قريبه في ساعات قليله تمكن مسلح حماس من
اسر عشرات الجنود والمستوطنين
الاسرائيليين بعد هجوم شنته عبر البر
والبحر والجو على مواقع للجيش الاسرائيلي
ومستوطنات في عمق اسرائيل لم يسبق ان وصلت
اليه الفصائل الفلسطينيه من قبل صدمه في
اسرائيل فالامر جلل بل ويوصف باكبر عمليه
عسكريه ضد اسرائيل منذ حرب اكتوبر
73 هي نكسه وفشل عسكري واستخباراتي غير
مسبوق والوصف هنا من قاده عسكريين في
اسرائيل رغم حاله الانكار الرسميه
الداخليه هذا المنظر اطلع اطلعي الشباب
الجيب وجاب اططط اطلع
الاسرائ سجده الشكر ان شاء الله على هذا
النصر اللهم اتم نصرك وعزك رب لشعبنا
وامتنا الله اكبر
الله
في الوقت الذي كانت فيه مقاتلات جيش
الاحتلال المزوده بالقنابل الفوسفوريه
المحرمه دوليا تضع ضمن بنك اهدافها
الاطفال مع عائلاتهم في بيوت غزه ولا تسمح
معايير النشر ببث الصور الفظيعه للجثث
وفيما اعاد مغردون عرب نشر صوره جندي
اسرائيلي يوم طاب له احتساء القهوه فوق
جثه طالبه فلسطينيه دون سن الرشد بعد
قتلها بدم بارد في مدينه الخليل كان
الفلسطينيون يرددون انهم حريصون على صوره
مغايره عن تعاملهم مع الاطفال ومع النساء
ما حدا هيسيبها عشان تعرف انسانيه عننا
ايوه استوها روها وخلوها لما تاخذوها حيه
اعرفوا خلو
تعرفها اطفال
بعد دخولهم قلت لهم لدي ولدان هذا اول شيء
قلته فنظر بعضهم الى بعض وردوا لا تقلقي
نحن مسلمون ولن
نؤذي شهد احدهم موزا في المطبخ ثم استاذني
في تناوله فقلت له تفضل في المقابل تركز
المقاتلات الاسرائيليه قصفها وتدميرها
وبالتالي قتلها على منازل المدن
ومساجد المسلمين ولم توفر ايضا سيارات
الاسعاف والطواقم
الطبيه الله كما تشاهدون خديجه هي غارات
فعلا هي الاعنف من بين تلك التي غطينا
وشاهدناها هكذا اصبحت غزه مدمره دمارا شبه
شامل بفعل اطنان المتفجرات التي يواصل
طيران الحرب الصهيوني القائها منذ
ساعات عن قرب تتكشف سياسه جديده للعدوان
اقرب لسياسه الارض
المحروقه لم تسلم بيوت الله من عنف
الاحتلال حيث تعرضت مساجد عده في غزه
للقصف دمر بعضها بالكامل منذ بدء العدوان
فجر السبت استشهد ابوك ما ابوك
استشهد استشهد ابوك
مستشهر
ابوكي
[تصفيق]
ابوك لا يا حبيبي
شه يا
الله يا الله يا الله يا الله ضربوا
الاسعاف ضربوا الاسعاف وضربوا ورا الاسعاف
في الاصابات في الاسعاف كان اكتر من ست
سبع اصابات كلهم
لماذا تقتل اسرائيل الاف المدنيين منذ
عقود بينما يسعى الفلسطينيون الى قتل
العسكريين حصرا واسر العسكريين والمدنيين
لمبادلتهم باسرا من المقاومين
والمدنيين سؤال اجاب عليه سابقا عضو
الكنيسه الاسرائيلي
زيفيكام الف ام فلسطينيه ولا تبكي ام
اسرائيليه واحده بينما يقول الرئيس
الكولومبي المنصف جوستافو بيترو ان
الطريقه الوحيده لكي ينام الاطفال
الاسرائيليون بسلام هي ان ينام الاطفال
الفلسطينيون بسلام عقيده عضو الكنيسه غير
مفاجئه لكن المدهش اعتباره جيشه رحيما
جدا
rac
forment
نازين هيهم هيهم ولك والله غير
نركيب تصرف كثير من المسافرين
الاسرائيليين بحكمه بالغه عندما عجلوا من
اجراءات سفرهم في اعقاب احداث لم تعهدها
اجيالهم من قبل وقد شاهد مطار بن جوريون
ازدحاما غير مسبوق بطوابير المغادرين
المذعورين اما من كان اكثر حكمه منهم فهم
وزراء الحكومه الاسرائيليه عندما انفضوا
عن جلستهم الحكوميه وفروا الى اقرب ملجا
خوفا من صواريخ المقاومه
الفلسطينيه تعليق جلسه الحكومه
الاسرائيليه في تل ابيب بسبب القصف المكثف
من قطاع غزه ودخول وزراء الى ملجا
مستوطنون اسرائيليون داخل غلاف غزه كانوا
اسرع من وزرائهم لم ينتظروا وصولهم الى
الملاجئ فاستقل اقرب حاويه للنفايات
عانقوا قمامات خوفا من نيران المقاومه
التي لا تميز بطبيعه الحال بين المراكز
العسكريه وحاويات النفايات المكشوفه ومن
كان منهم اكثر همه ويتمتع ع بلياقه رياضيه
فقد فضل الدخول في سباق جري دون سيارات
لمغادره حفله صاخبه في احدى مستوطنات غلاف
غزه لكن العائله الاسرائيليه التي لا
تستطيع ان تسامح حكومه تل ابيب هي اسره
مستوطن في عسقلان قتله جيش الاحتلال سهوا
وهوس بعدما اشتبه في ان يكون مقاوما
فلسطينيا واضح هناك حاله هوس وتسلل حتى
انه قتل اسرائيل بسبب زائده في عسقلان
وتهوره كما وصف من قبل الاعلام الاسرائيلي
للاشتباه لمجرد انه يعتقد انه فلسطيني
الخارجيه الاسرائيليه لا تريد اي اجتهاد
من سفرائها او رعاياها في الخارج فمنعت
السفراء من التجول في اي مكان بالعالم دون
اذن مسبق وطلبت من الاسرائيليين في الخارج
توخي الحذر اما من هم في مصر عليهم
مغادرتها فورا ففي الاسكندريه شرطي مصري
يطلق النار على سياح اسرائيليين ويقتل
منهم اثنين وصرح مصدر الامني المصري بانه
تم ضبط فرد من الشرطه قام باطلاق عيره
الاريه من سلاحه الشخصي بشكل عشوائي مما
اسفر عن وفاه اثنين من اعضاء احد الافواج
السياحيه الاسرائيليه في منطقه مزار عمود
الصواري بمنطقه المنشيه بالاسكندريه
بالاضافه الى احد المصريين واصابه اخر
هناك نوع ثالث من محللين وناشطين عرب
ليسوا مؤيدين للمقاومه بالطبع ولا ينتقدون
خياراتها بل يؤيدون اسرائيل ويخونون
المقاومه او يكفرونه للاسف الشديد اللي
قاعده تكون فيه حماس ارهاب وتشويه لصوره
الاسلام
والمسلمين يجب تكثيف كل الجهود من اجل
القضاء على الارهاب لا عندهم لا دين ولا
اخلاق ولا شيء ندين ونستنكر العمليات
الارهابيه التي قامت بها ميليشيات ايران
في فلسطين ميليشيات حماس الارهابيه في غزه
ضد المدنيين ضد الاطفال والنساء في دوله
اسرائيل في المقابل الممثله الاباحيه
السابقه 100 خليفه تدافع عن الفلسطينيين
وترد على من يدعون بان اسرائيل تعتدي بسبب
حماس فتقول ان اسرائيل لم تحتل اراضي
الفلسطينيين
حماس هلا عن جد عن جد وبدون ما حدا يفهمني
غلط ليش مام بتحلل سياسه والشباب ما بحلل
سياسه ينسجم مع كلام المتطرفين من
المطبعين كلام وزير الدفاع عن اسرائيل يوف
جالانت الذي لم ترضعه سيبته عن وصف
الفلسطينيين بالحيوانات
البشريه معلق فلسطيني جره جالنت الى
مستواه المتدني في التعبير فرد عليه نحن
وانتم حيوانات بشريه لكن شتان شتان ما بين
الاسود
والخنازير
يقول
مخلط
خشم
مزون
دلك وان به جيش الوزير جالنت يخوض معركه
اسقاط السراويل بدل معركه السيوف الحديديه
التي اعلنتها اسرائيل الوصف السراويل تسجل
حقوقه لصحيفه هرتس العبريه التي اقرت
بهزيمه اسرائيل
وسخرت من كبار الضباط الذين اعتقلوا
بملابسهم الداخليه فيما فر اخرون للاختباء
في المراحيض
[موسيقى]
العامه مجنده اسرائيليه سابقه خدمت على
الحدود مع قطاع غزه تقول من مستحيل توغل
القسام كل هذه المسافه دون ان يكون عندنا
علم فهل هناك من تعاون معهم من الجي تسال
ست بتكلم على انه لو حشره يعني احنا
بنتكلم مش مش الف مقاتل مش ناس جايه يا
جماعه القوات بتاعه حماسك جايه معاها جرار
عارف يعني ايه
جرار جرار وقطعوا جزء من الجدار وعدوا منه
على خط طوفان الاقصى يتصاعد التوتر على
الحدود اللبنانيه الجنوبيه مع
فلسطين قضائ مدفعيه وصواريخ موجهه يطلقها
حزب الله تستهدف مواقع اسرائيليه في مزارع
شبع المحتله ويرد عليها الاسرائيلي وفيما
يعلن المتحدث باسمه استعداد الجيش لمواجهه
جميع السيناريوهات تحتشد دبابات اسرائيليه
على طول الحدود مع لبنان وتعز وزاره
الدفاع الاسرائيليه بالاستعداد لاخلاء
المستوطنات القريبه من الحدود اللبنانيه
العميد المتقاعد في الجيش الامريكي مارك
كيمت يحذر اسرائيل من انجرافها الى قتال
واسع في غزه فهي ستكون محاصره بالكامل من
مح محور المقاومه في فلسطين ولبنان وسوريا
يقول take
look the surrounding isra right now also
about in
syan in
are
could
كلام اسرائيلي عميق مطابق لرؤيه العميد
الاميريكي اطلقه الباحث العبري موردخاي
كيدار الذي نصح المستوطنين بالاستعداد
لسيناريوهات ما وصفه بيوم القيامه في
اسرائيل الاف الصواريخ من كل الجهات
مسيرات انتحاريه هجوم سيبراني يشل الحياه
تعطيل تام للبنى التحتيه اجواء مغل
طيران عاجز عن التحليق قبه حديديه بلا
مخزون وانهيار كامل للجيش الاسرائيلي خلال
ساعات ثم اجتياح بري للسيطره على
المستوطنات انه سيناريو يوم القيامه في
اسرائيل راسم خطوطه العريضه ليس محور
المقاومه انما هو الكاتب والباحث
الاسرائيلي مردخاي
كدار خرج عن صمته محذرا من هجوم عسكري
قريب منسق ومشترك ومنظم يشمل ايران ولبنان
وسوريا والعراق واليمن وقطاع غزه والضفه
الغربيه والداخل المحتل ويختم مردخاي
بنصيحه للمستوطنين ان كنتم تحبون الحياه
فعليكم ان تستيقظوا وتستعد وهل ستسمح
امريكا وحلفاؤها بهزيمه لاسرائيل
اكبر حامله طائرات امريكيه تطوف البحر
لدعم اسرائيل
وزعماء امريكا وبريطانيا والمانيا
وايطاليا وفرنسا وقفوا على قلب رجل واحد
دعما لاسرائيل خساره اسرائيل ليست امرا
فظيعا للغرب يقول مردخاي ويضيف ان واشنطن
والحكومات الاوروبيه لن تتدخل عسكريا
لانقاذها فلا يبحث احد عن ساحه قتال اخرى
الى جانب اوكرانيا التي تفرغ مستودعات حلف
الناتو ورد في تقرير يوم القيامه في اسرا
كلام عن مشاركه سوريا في الحرب فهل
التوقيت مناسب للنظام في دمشق حيث انه
منشغل الان بادلب وريف حلب وتشكيله جديده
من قنابل النابالم انه النابالم المحرم
دوليا يحرق قرى وبلدات الشمال السوري نظام
الاسد يعيدها سيرتها الاولى طالبا
بالاتفاقات الدوليه كل الجدر ممطرا قرى
وبلدات ريفي ادلب وحلب جميع انواع الجحيم
قنابل عنقوديه وصواريخ فراغيه وقذائف
مدفعيه وغارات جويه في كل ساعه استهدفت
خلال عده ايام
22 قريه وبلده
وخارطة غضبه على الهواء في وجه احمد الذي
يبدو انه استعمل طريقه للعلاج يعتمدها بعض
الاطباء النفسانيين انت الان افخاي هل
تشعر بالهزيمه بالمهانه مما حدث صباح
اليوم
لكم مهما حاولتم فلن تكسروا ارادتنا شعب
اسرائيل حيص بمص المقاومه ننتصر عسكريا
واعلاميا ومهما ح وتم وجندت كل الطاقات
وما الى ذلك وتخدمون كل هذه الصفات لن
تستطيعوا كسر ارادتنا اخيرا نهدي هذه
الحلقه الى المظلومين في فلسطين وفي كل
مكان بالعالم ونهديها ايضا بشكل خاص الى
حسام زملط رئيس البعثه الفلسطينيه في
بريطانيا انه دبلوماسي بالف يتنقل من شاشه
الى منبر لاقامه الحجه على اهل الكلام قبل
دوله
الاحتلال is
not whether you support their action or
not is question is not question a group
isit group talking with the palestinian
represent our position is very well know
and is not about support or not support
i am here to represent my people the
palestinian people how many times you
have interviewed israel officials louise
hundreds of times hundreds of times how
many times israel have committed war
crimes right live on your own cameras do
you start by asking them to condemn
themselves have you you don't you don't
no no i'll answer that question you
don't you know why i refuse to answer
this question because i refuse the
premise of it because at the very heart
of it is misrepresentation of the
[موسيقى]
ختاما يحكى ان رجلا يقال له جبرا قد سطى
بالقوه على بيت احمد في وسط المدينه وحول
المسلوب الى ملكيه له في سجلات بلديه
المهيمنه طردت الاسره في وضح النهار وقتلت
عصابه جبر بعض ابنائها فاكمل الحاج احمد
ما تبقى له من عمر تحت خيمه قرب البيت
يزرع في عقول ابنائه وبناته وصيته بالعوده
الى ملكهم وتراثهم وصور سقوق الارض
ومفاتيح الدار مات احمد في الغربه شهيدا
دون اهله و ضه في اليوم الذي ولد فيه
حفيده احمد كبر الحفيد وسطوه جبره تشتد في
المدينه حيث هجر معظم اهلها وسلبهم بيوتهم
ومزارعهم قرر المستضعفون رفع اصواتهم
بمكبرات تحول المفردات الى رصاصات عملا
بوصيه احمد التي كتبها كبروا اصواتكم
وكبروا الدار داركم والدنيا تدور فدوروا
مع الحق حيث دار الى اللقاء اسرايل قامت
على الظلم
والاغتصاب فيكل كيان يقوم على الظلم
والاغتصاب
مصير الدمار حتى لو يملك القوه التي تؤهله
للبقاء القوه لا تدوم قلت قلت ان القوه في
العالم لا تدوم لاحد الطفل يبدا طفل ثم
مراهق ثم شباب ثم كاهل ثم شيخ خلاص تيك
الدول تيك عمر الدول تبدا وتبدا وتبدا
تنتهي للاندثار ما في فائده وفي اي مرحله
اسرائيل الان انا اقول ان اسرائيل بائده
ان شاء الله في القرن القادم في الربع
الاول منه وبالتحديد انا بقول 2027 بتكون
اسرائيل مش
[موسيقى]
موجوده
ن